before the video starts i'm trying to
raise three hundred thousand meals for
one thousand families in pakistan
yemen somalia bangladesh born sisters
inshallah help us feed them this ramadan
to open and break their fast and you're
charging ten thousand
twenty thousand and they knew they're
talking about the prophet sallallahu
assalamu said the one who gives orphan
and vin would be like this in jannah
subhanallah
you're there talking about this then
often you really care about orphans
but if you're doing it just for the
money if you're doing it just for the
faith
just for the views prophet says this is
dangerous
three people on the day of judgement
muslims
are going to enter the fire the one who
recited quran the one who gave in sadaka
i don't i want to say i've been meaning
to do this video uh for a long time but
i think it's an important reminder this
reminder is something that is close home
to me
so this reminder goes to me first before
anyone else i don't want this to be
felt by anyone that's watching this that
i'm targeting you but i've been
targeting myself and i carry on
targeting myself and i should
carry on doing my brothers and sisters
subhanallah and subhanallah one of the
greatest
scholars i i forgot his name said
i have not fought with anything as hard
as is my intentions
for one day it is against me and the
next day it is for me
brothers and sisters i can really
really really relate to this statement
in the thousand brothers and sisters you
are hit with a lot of stuff
you are hit with attention from as as
men you are hit with attention from
females
yeah attention yeah let's be real here
you'll get the attention of fame you've
been stopped every now and then taking
pictures etc
you've got the fitna of even money
coming into it
and this is the reason why i'm doing
this video problems is because this is a
reminder to myselfers well
i genuinely everything i'm saying i'm
not here to have the
high horse like you know i'm the reason
it's coming from me i don't see much
people speaking about it and we have to
be real
because brothers and sisters this is a
massive problem and
if we don't touch upon it it's going to
destroy us how is it especially with the
brothers
and sisters in the tower scene we do not
want to be a candle
that gives light to everyone and burns
herself off and i'm not talking about
burn myself up by
being tired no what i'm talking about is
we end up in the fire
why do we end up in the fire because we
did our dawah for what reason
we did it for the money we did it for
the fame we did it for the attention for
the
uh for the females for whatever reason
it may be fame
money and all that kind of stuff so we
have to really feel allah subhanahu wa
tala
and the reason i'm doing this video is
because there's certain things i've
observed there's certain things i've
seen within myself
and my surroundings and the brothers
that i work with whether it may be it's
no one's specific just in general
yeah and we really really need to
understand brothers and sisters
yeah the dowel channels that we have the
dowel personalities
if we do not do this for the sake of
allah and i know it's damn hard
i know one life sometimes i i i
i came to a point where i was going to
and my teachers testified to this i
really wanted to leave the tower
because i couldn't reconcile i was like
am i doing this for the right reasons am
i doing this for the right reasons am i
doing this right
i was losing my mind over it while i was
getting depressed because i don't want
to stand in front of allah and allah
says
everything you've done you did it for
the fame
you did it for the attention of the
females you did it for the uh for the
money
or this that so much so i didn't want to
get paid by youtube for five years i
just
straight to stay away from it
alhamdulillah that was the biggest
blessing because at least i can look
back and say
you know um because recently like about
two years ago i started monetizing
uh because youtube allowed us to block
certain ads and they will put ads on our
videos anyways
so alhamdulillah we spoke to people of
knowledge etc
you know and subhanallah we came
decision that we can monetize but we
block certain at times with allah
and even then sometimes things come up
which is out of our control that's what
allah we've consulted with our teachers
the point is this one sisters yeah even
then i'm thinking man if i started
monetizing my channel from the get-go
i would genuinely question myself why am
i doing this but
knowing that i did it five years at
least it gives me a bit of peace of mind
like
okay i wasn't doing it for the money and
so much so brothers and sisters
sometimes i'm doing like i'm involved
like i'm like 100 a little money
i make i try to invest in certain places
hamdulillah look i don't even need to do
uber anymore in the context where i'm
done i've got other options etc
i'm working i've gone doing different
stuff different jobs et cetera bomb
sisters
um and trying to start like a little
business for myself the thing is this
one and sisters
even then i'm thinking i need to go back
to uber because it keeps me
on in check do you know what i'm trying
to say um and it keeps me like you know
at least like it's just another source
of income
i don't even want to be paid by the
da'wah like genuinely
so concerned we work for certain
organizations sometimes i do live
appeals to iman alhamdulillah
and different places so you do get like
you can make like alhamdulillah
some kind of a living but the point is
this problem says and that's normal
there's nothing wrong with that you know
handling
that i'm not saying presenters i'm not
talking about that yet
but the point is this brothers and
sisters yeah us in the tower we have to
be our our our standards have to be high
yeah
because this is the dean of allah if we
do something wrong or if we
are perceived as someone who is just
money motivated or fame
motivated or other things brothers and
sisters is going to damage the tower
people is going to perceive us in a
different way
and finding some one example i can give
in the speaker's corner i see brothers
and
i'm being honest the same with me yeah
running for content
running oh i need to upload it before
etc the question we need to ask is why
why are you in competition and this goes
to me
promises this goes to me and which i try
my best to battle it
why are you running brothers please
please and sisters who are in the tower
ask yourself a question if you have
rivalry
rivalry not a healthy competition
if you have a rivalry where you want to
get a specific content before because of
views
ask yourself a question why do i feel
like that
if money is involved ask yourself a
question
if you have started because shaytan's
going to come and creep in you slowly
install this load and when you have
these tower channels
a lot of things are open to you i get a
lot of people coming and saying brother
can you share this accessory i'll give
you money i'll give you money at this
like that
the options are open if i was to say yes
i would be
bowling what are we putting like i'm
trying this i'm not wondering i'm not
trying to have the high horses
allah is my witness may allah forgive me
if i'm trying to become this humble guy
who's trying to come to you like
one lie i struggle with this myself
genuinely guys
i have this opportunity when i'm looking
brother if i have some money from there
bro that's a lot of money
but sometimes i have to fight the nerfs
and say no aki
no problem you don't need to pay me
because as long as i'm making enough my
thing is this as long as i'm making
enough to pay my rent my shopping
yeah my wife's you know if my my wife
needs finances whatever it may be
or whatever my kids etc and whatever
[ __ ] little save
as long as i've got that it's fine but
if i am just like no money money money i
need to my own
provinces one lie this will destroy your
heart if you're in the dawah
and all your occupied money is
supernatural we hear people who want to
give khutbah
for grants thousands now what five
thousand pounds why what
do people refuse into the khutbah why no
if you want me to i heard a story
somebody
the imam didn't come and they asked the
famous sheikh
can you give her oh if you give me
eleven twelve
thousand something i'm thinking what oh
give me first class tickets brothers and
sisters we need to combat this
even if they give us the option yeah
even if they give us the option
we need to say no thank you yeah if they
come and say brother we'll give you
first class
plane ticket no i don't need first class
playing ticket brother
yeah i don't need first class plane
ticket we have to fight our nerfs but if
we say oh no you know i deserve it no
we need to fight that we can't just be
like oh yeah take it from here he's
giving it
you have to keep yourself in check
perhaps you need to keep yourself in
check
we can't have this attitude where
everything is money money money
if you need to make a living
understandable there's certain things
you can do that's totally understandable
but if you're doing it just for the
money if you're doing it just for the
faith
just for the views prophecy this is
dangerous
three people on the day of judgment
muslims
are going to enter the fire the one who
recited quran the one who gave him
sadaqah the one who fought for the sake
of allah
how could these people end up in the
fire i'm asking you how how
how is scary how are these people what
life scary
the one who said the quran allah asked
him what did you do for my sake
oh allah i just recited a quran and i
spread you're a liar allah is going to
say
you're a kava you did it so people can
say he's a knowledgeable person
ah students of knowledge yeah you're
trying to be knowledgeable i don't
i don't people see that oh i need to
make sure that you know i came arabic
right before the video oh is it really
why brother why
why if you make a mistake why your
reputation is going to be on the line
number two the one who gave in sadaqah
in zakah
allah asked what did you do for my sake
oh allah gave him sadaqah
you're a liar kevin you did it so people
can say what a generous man he's such a
generous man
and the one who fought for his sake
allah is going to say what you do for me
i'll fall for your sake
you're the liar allah is going to say
you did it so people can say what a
brave man what a warrior
yeah okay brothers and sisters
please this is a reminder everyone and
people have youtube ads
they've monetized on their channels
quran is being played next video is of
alcohol
next video is of next level stuff half
naked girls
coming out these are for youtube
channels if you're earning your money is
haram
all this kind of stuff
filter your ads filter your ads
even if you're online even if your money
that you're making goes half wall
is better for you it's better for you
brothers and sisters this is just a
reminder
to dow challenge and this goes to me
need to feel allah
we need to make sure that we do not give
this perception to people
subhanallah that it's all about money i
don't want people to think because it's
the dean of allah it's not about me
if i go and say yes i'm going to charge
you for this sponsor this time i've had
sponsorships
yeah i have an agreement on sponsorship
yes i myself do
but those who i work with they know very
clearly alhamdulillah yeah
okay if they can't afford it i'll do it
for free so brahmana sisters what i'm
trying to say is this
yeah you to earn and live in an income
in the dow is fine to be even paid by
tawa
is okay it's okay but the point is if
you're doing it just for the money
and it's become an enterprise it's
become a franchise
yeah where my channel my channel my
channel etc
you know i've had moments where i've
seen certain um
individuals yeah certain channels and
while
i've brothers close to me have
controlled me that i said i'm going to
refute this channel
in public or this person in public
why because of a b c d a b c
d we're human beings we assume the best
but when we see something with idiots we
become idiots more than a second brother
this isn't once twice
oh views this that caring about oh just
channel channel channel
brothers and sisters please i'm just
gonna end on this i'm not i'm going on a
tantrum so sorry
but guys in a nutshell we need to feel
like the darwin scenes
and we cannot make this we've got
presenters who are charging thousands of
pounds to present
we need to have a cap there has to be
somewhere we say hold on a second we
don't cross the line here
we can i'm not going to say it's sinful
we can
we have people subhanallah like imagine
raising funds
for the poor or the mesquite the orphans
and you're charging ten thousand
twenty thousand and they knew they're
talking about the prophet sallallahu
sallallahu said the one who gives to
orphan
and uh vin will be like this in jannah
subhanallah
you're there talking about this then
often you really care about orphans
you really care about orphans yeah let's
see why charging 10 grand 20 grand
ridiculous amount huh why don't you cap
yourself and say you know what
okay i deserve i say whatever i have the
following i'm a famous person
two grand whatever it may be yeah ten
grand twenty grand then you come and say
brother sisters allah says
allah said that the person said the one
who helps the orphan
you're taking from the office money what
are you talking about
anyways that's it brother sisters that
was my tantrum i'm so sorry i had to get
off my chest
really annoyed me and once again this is
a reminder to myself first
wallahi i'll be honest with you i don't
i don't think i can stand in front of
allah and say oh laughter than thou for
your sake
i don't know only thing that i can know
and that's keeping me sane and keeping
me in the tawa
is that i focus on my private deeds as
much as i can
whatever i can do so at least i could
say oh allah that was that was for you
there was no one there to see that was
between me and you i can't stand in
front of allah
if allah accepts it alhamdulillah if he
doesn't
i'm not even coming there with that if
allah says what you've done to me
private deeds i don't know tawa i don't
know
may allah purify intention says ramadan
we're fasting may allah pray for
intentions may allah protect
us but there is nothing more scary than
to die
than to to to and this should be with
every one of us
to think well can you imagine standing
in front of allah
yeah can you imagine standing in front
of allah and allah says to you what
you've done for me
and you say allah don't die with you and
he says you're a convert
you're a liar brothers and sisters
wallahi may allah protect us
there is nothing that is more scary than
what